speaker Barbara disco she is a professor
at MIT where she is the head of the
programming mythology group doing
research on now VST and distributed
computing she is the first woman to win
a PhD in computer science in the US and
I'm gonna go through a list a very small
sampler of distinctions awards and
things that I can sell right here
because I really want to end up going to
fur but believe me the laces are very
long so in terms of awards in 2004 she
was a phenomenal for fundamental
contributions to programming languages
for the new methodology and distributed
systems 19 2008 she won the Turing Award
for her contributions to practical
experiment foundations of programming
languages and system design especially
related to data abstraction fault
tolerance and distributed computing
normally after the Turing Awards people
don't bother to continue but in her case
injustice women failed 12 she was
inducted to the National Inventors Hall
of Fame and this continues a list of
memberships and honors she's the member
of the National Academy of Engineers and
I thought I've been obsessing she's a
fellow of the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences and a fellow of the ACM and
she has several which I won't count on
two honorary doctorates mostly from
European universities that I would
anyway the bitumen of lineage she was
advised at Stanford I believe by a
professor of McCarthy himself attorney
Award winner in 71 if this was anybody
knows yes yes yes don't have to play
chess and also in terms of lineage has
some one or more advisees in the
auditorium here today except for those
at fancies does anybody though here
names room yeah yeah so I think that we
could do a very simple mathematical
extrapolation from from Farsi touring
barber ass you know it took let's see 27
years I think between the two wrinkled
words so we can extrapolate okay and we
learned I'm very pleased to have you
[Applause]
solve the problem already okay so I want
to make sure everybody can hear me yes
okay so in a way I'm here under false
pretenses because I don't really work on
block chains and I'm here because of the
work I did on practical Byzantine
fault-tolerance and what I'm gonna do
today
oops that was not a good idea
first I'm going to talk a little bit
about how practical Byzantine fault
tolerance came about and then I'll talk
about some recent work I've been doing
with Luba shreya and Morris Herlihy on
cross chain deals and I'll end up with
some thoughts about replication okay so
I need to go back in time to around 1997
and at that point my group was working
on a we were very involved in research
on distributed computing and it was
broadly interpreted because it included
work on programming language as anything
and should be computing was kind of fair
game the group was focused on a
client-server server object store some
of the stuff that came out of the group
at that time just to mention a couple
things this is distributed information
flow control Andrew Myers that's had a
lot of impact in the systems community
distribute garbage collection that was a
mishmash wari a very cystic ated lovely
simple algorithm for managing garbage
over a distributed system I had a very
talented group of graduate students and
one of them was Miguel Castro and Miguel
was looking for a thesis topic in around
1997 I don't remember exactly when and I
suggested to him that he go and look at
the DARPA RFPs the request for proposals
and what had happened was that the
internet was now out in the public and
bad behavior was becoming a very
important issue and so DARPA had an RFP
asking for ideas about how we could
manage some of the problems that were
happening on the internet and so Miguel
saw that RFP and he suggested to me that
maybe we should work on Byzantine fault
tolerant replication
and I put the word practical there in
red because of course there was
theoretical work on Byzantine fault
tolerant replication already in
existence but we were concerned about
how do you come up with a system a way
of doing it a protocol that you could
actually use in practice now one of the
things I was thinking about as I was
getting this talk together was what was
it that caused Miguel to come up with
this topic I mean first of all if you
think about graduate students they don't
all come up with their own topics we
can't come up with this by himself and I
think the reason he was able to do this
was because of the history of the group
okay so now I've gone back to the early
1980s when I first started working in
distributed computing and one of the
things that was disturbing me at that
time and this is maybe around nineteen
eighty-four eighty-five distributed
remote file systems had come into
existence by then and I was concerned
about the following problem when you
have the files on your own machine you
know if your machines up your files are
there if your machines down you can't
get at them but if they're it's up you
can get them once you have a remote file
system in those days there were two
reasons why you couldn't get your files
if your local machine was up you still
wouldn't be able to get them if there
was a problem with the internet or that
machine where your files were stored was
down and so I started to think about
what to do about this and it was clear
that we needed replication and people
were thinking about this but it's not an
easy problem because you have to have a
system it's got to be a replicated state
machine and it has to work properly in
the presence of concurrency and even
more important in the presence of
failures and it's critically important
that when somebody logs in tomorrow
after failure what they see tomorrow is
consistent with what happened today and
there was work on the time but it was
mostly thinking about having the user
control thing so it was kind of like a
locking solution and that wasn't working
very well so I started to work on this
problem
I was working primarily with one of my
students Brian okie and we came up with
a strategy
how to do this so those are the issues
and I said this already
okay so onward the the strategy that
came up with was fundamentally what
we're all using for replication today in
this sort of train of research we
decided one of the replicas would be
acting as the primary it would tell the
backups what to do they would do exactly
what it said but of course they had and
of course the primary would wait long
enough to know that the backups knew
what was going on before letting the
client know what was the answer but the
backups were mean while watching the
primary because the primary might fail
and in that case they would carry out a
second algorithm of you change algorithm
simple you know actually this stuff
seems trivial to me now but you know it
was hard to come up with them and this
is basically by the way paxos it's just
that I didn't understand that Leslie
didn't understand that and I actually
saw Leslie give a talk at MIT and about
the time we were writing a paper on this
and he was dressed in a toga and jugg
you know it was very mysterious and I
had no idea he was talking about the
same thing okay and the one point I
wanted to make out this is mrs. crash
failures so this is not business team
failure so no so it's simple failure
model nodes are up or down network
either delivers good messages or
recognizably bad ones or it doesn't
deliver them simple model okay and the
replicas main chain walks which of
course are fundamentally immutable
Ledger's okay so I think the reason
Miguel thought one reason why Miguel
thought this up was because unlike
almost everybody in the country my group
knew about this kind of replication it
was sort of in our DNA there's the
there's the papers that we published
they see this is late nineteen 1988
another paper the first one was about
replication in the presence of the
database the second was about a file
system these are not great papers by the
way I mean that paper is not as readable
as it could have been and the reason is
that I we didn't fully separate the
algorithm from the application they sat
behind it so you know partly it's less
Lee's fault for not
anything so much later and partly it's
my fault for not going back and
rewriting this stuff at the time I've
subsequently rewritten it and of course
many other people have done similar
things okay so the point is my group
knew about this work so Miguel knew
about this work and so for us we had
this advantage that other groups really
didn't have we had this sitting there we
knew how this system worked so it was an
easier job for us to take that next step
so Miguel and I started to work on this
problem darpur was happy with the
proposal and we got some money and we
started to work on this project so this
is now around 1997 when we young came up
with this idea and we used exactly the
same strategy so the primary runs the
protocol it orders the requests the
backups are going to watch the primary
and we'll do a view change if they don't
like what they see okay they maintain
logs just what we were doing before but
of course there's a huge difference here
because once you acknowledge that you're
talking about businessing failures where
the replicas can lie the network can be
malicious
you know everything changes so just
because the primary said do it doesn't
mean that you should obey it because the
primary might be bad so you have to
handle all those corner cases it took us
quite a while to figure out how to do it
but the grounding in the earlier system
for stamp replication was a big help
now you all know this stuff and this
stuff existed before we started this
work but one of the things that happens
in the system is that the you need more
replicas so for simple failure
resilience you need to F plus one here
you need three F plus one because if you
look at this picture what you see is
that we're running some operation and we
can never wait for that last replica to
reply because of course it might be down
or maybe it never got the message in
this case it didn't get the message
so we have to be able to go forward with
one of those replicas not responding
this is the F equal one case but of
course as is the case here the replica
that didn't respond is actually an
honest replica and one of the replicas
that responded is the bad replica and
now imagine that there's a view change
okay so now there's a view change and we
lost an honest replica but because our
quorums are big enough what we know is
that we have an honest replica in there
somewhere that knows what happened we
have that liar and then we have this guy
that's clueless over here now notice
there's another problem here so we need
these bigger quorums but there's another
problem here we have the guy who
actually knows what went on and we have
the liar how do we distinguish between
them when we go on to the view change
how do we know which one's telling the
truth so everything in here is done with
cryptography everything has to be done
with certificates that prove that this
is what the state really was so I'm not
going to bore you with you know this
discussion of how this worked but
basically what happened is you can see
pbft as an extension of the view stamp
replication protocol where the quorums
were more there was an extra phase in
the protocol what we called the
pre-prepare this had to do with the fact
that the primary might be lying and so
you couldn't act on what the primary
said you had to first of all get sort of
the group to agree that that was the
right next step so there was an extra
phase in the protocol and we use
certificates to handle the case that
replicas could lie so how do you know
what the truth is
and then view changes as I was
discussing a moment ago and we
maintained a log and we had blocks
because this is expensive it's not
hugely expensive but it's expensive and
you want to amortize the cost of running
the protocol across many client requests
okay a couple of other things I just
want to mention here before I move on is
that the log we were thinking of was not
something that the replicas understood
it was a set of client requests it knew
what clients it was talking to so it
knew this was the 25th client request
from that client but it did not know the
content of the messages and it did not
try to execute this stuff I thought of
this log and I still think this is
what's going on in blockchains really is
that they're just a set of calls on
operations of an underlying application
and this is the system sitting in front
of the application in our thinking that
ordered things in vamped so the applique
which was replicated could be operating
correctly okay
and by the way Miguel had a kind of a
proof that this worked in his thesis
because it was it's a complicated
algorithm even though it seems simple
compared to stuff that's happened in the
future and there's been other work in
the systems community really working on
the proof of correctness of this stuff
okay so I'm there's the paper and I'm
gonna go on now and talk about a
different topic okay so what I'm going
to talk about next is some work I've
been doing with Morris and Luba on cross
chain deals so if in fact block chains
turn out to be a thing that is really
used in practice we have to imagine that
there's going to be a lot of them and if
there's going to be computations that
are going to use more than one of them
and so how do you make those
computations run and the problem is what
I see on my screen oh I'm sorry I left
something out before I get there let me
just say something about this so I yes I
wanted to mention so here it is mm
Miguel has finished his thesis we both
think about pbft we say gee will this
ever be used you know I don't know maybe
it'll be used for a key distribution
center mind you the view stamp
replication stuff was finally starting
to be used in 2012 years after it was
invented so you know you expect a kind
of a lag time like this between research
and what happens out in the real world
but you know we didn't think he'd be
used very much we kind of thought you
know what will f be well you know maybe
it'd be 2 or 3 we weren't sure and then
we both went on and did other stuff ok
and then you know along in 2009 the
paper on Bitcoin appeared and it wanted
a persistent immutable of ledger and
this is basically the killer app for
pbft so and not that I paid any
attention to this whatsoever I was
completely ignorant but it was just kind
of amusing that this happened okay so
now we're today and I'm going to talk
about some recent work and as I said
this is work that I did with Luba and
Morris and I'm going to talk about just
a piece of what we talked about in that
paper Luba has other things too I mean
Luba Morris is going to talk about other
stuff ok so what's a cross chain deal
here's an example Bob wants to sell two
tickets 400 coins alice is a broker and
she's happy to buy those tickets 400
coins and sell them to Carol for 101
coins so the idea is Bob sells the
tickets Carol gets the coins I mean
celsa tickets and gets the coins Carol
gets the tickets and Alice gets a little
fee for being a broker
okay so we're living in a world where
the blockchains manage assets so there's
a ticket blockchain a coin blockchain
the parties exchange the assets online
and we want a protocol that's going to
make all of this work okay
now it's kind of like an atomic
transaction and Morse is going to talk
more about this this afternoon I mean
you have this idea that the deals either
going to go through or it isn't but it's
a weird environment I mean in a way when
I was working on pbft I felt like I had
entered a Hall of Mirrors
you know you had to think so strangely
about the fact that everybody could be
corrupt actually only F could be corrupt
here everybody can be corrupt and they
may have agendas that you know nothing
about maybe the agenda is just to have
the other by loses as his assets and you
don't care if you gain anything it's
very it's a very corrupt world and they
might collude and there's no limit on
how many of them can be bad so there
could be 20 of them in 19 get together
and try to achieve xx so you have to
handle all those cases now clearly there
are certain acceptable outcomes so
here's an acceptable outcome Carol gets
the tickets Bob gets the coins Alice
gets the feet another acceptable outfit
is that Bob keeps the tickets Carol
keeps the coins Alice gets nothing
okay you can define what this means but
that's a sort of an acceptable outcome
that's like a commit the first one like
an abort the second one okay here are
obviously unacceptable outcomes Carol
gets the ticket but Bob doesn't get his
money that's clearly doesn't seem
acceptable another one is the assets are
tied up forever
and the current work on what are called
cross chain swaps I'm gonna show you
what happens with that so there's been
work on this issue how do I run these
deals it's been limited it doesn't
handle full deals it handles what are
called swaps an idea of a swap is that
take Alice out of the picture Bob is
offering his tickets Karen's going to
give him the coin so the two of them are
involved in a direct exchange of assets
and the current community protocols that
exist for this are fully decentralized
and they assume synchronous
communication okay and here's just
what's going on I'm not going to
describe these protocols in any detail
but the idea is that you start off by
putting the assets into escrow this is
like locks and a transaction system you
put the acid into escrow this means that
it's locked up it's there for a
particular party if the thing should go
through otherwise it's going to revert
to the owner if something goes wrong and
but it's locked up okay and then the
parties are working on this protocol and
they put their assets into escrow
actually in a particular order in these
particular protocols and then when
things are kind of okay for somebody
they claim their incoming asset by
saying commit and the commit since these
are malicious has to have some kind of
proof that it's okay to release that
asset so yeah
oh sorry about that Saudi is the deal
okay a is the asset so that's
identifying a particular ticket or a
certain amount of coins H is I'll get to
in a minute and T is also something
that's a time okay so the proof that
commit D P what P is it reveals the
secret that H is hiding so the simple
way that one of these deals works is Bob
puts his tickets into escrow with a hash
of a secret he invented Alice sees this
and she puts her coins into escrow with
that same hash when Bob sees the coins
he can renew the commits really
revealing the secret and then when Alice
sees that commit she can take that
secret and get her at her tickets so
that's the way this protocol works okay
but remember these are malicious parties
and maybe Carol's secret agenda is she's
not going to give the coins to Bob and
but she just wants him to lose his
tickets okay and there isn't any way of
saying abort here instead what happens
is the commit must get there in time so
that T is a time by which the commit
must arrive if it doesn't arrive by then
the asset is returns to whoever provided
it okay and this is in a timed model a
synchronous communication model so the
idea is you can select such a time now
you're going to be careful about
selecting that time you know it's going
to be pretty far in the future okay but
it's absolutely true that this is a
possible outcome so I put in red the
fact that in fact Bob might get the
money but Carol doesn't get her tickets
Bob releases his secret but Carol
doesn't get the commit there in time and
so she doesn't get her tickets okay
Carol is the one at risk in this
particular example but we solved the
problem of the assets are turned up tied
up forever and you know there's nothing
surprising going on here I mean after
all we know the network is really
asynchronous right and in an
asynchronous world you can't have both
safety and liveness
what's happened here is we've chosen
liveness over safety okay and although
you can choose a time in the future and
maybe it's pretty likely that everything
will be okay still there could be a
denial-of-service attack and that would
cause somebody do not get there in time
so it's a real issue and to me coming as
I do out of consistency in transactions
and stuff like that it's disgusting I
really don't like it okay so I was
asking the question I started to work
with Luba and Morris and the answer is
yes but we have to have some shared
resource that everybody is willing to
trust okay that other protocol didn't
have such a shared resource I mean it
didn't have something the state of the
deal the way I'll show you in a minute
so we're gonna have a shared resource
but in the system's community we talked
to about four years as a white board we
had this idea that was this thing
sitting out there it was an application
you could be riding on it everybody
could look at it they could sort of see
what the story was we're gonna actually
it doesn't have to be a blockchain it
could be a database but we're gonna use
a blockchain here and this is what we
call the certified blockchain okay and
the idea is that this blockchain is
going to be used to record the status of
the deal so the status of the deal is
going to be doesn't exist yet
but if it exists it's either active or
it's committed or it's aborted okay so
now I'm going to just run through the
protocol
the way this thing starts is that some
party to the deal and by the way this is
general protocol that carry handles more
than swaps it can handle that example I
gave you earlier with Alice and another
thing I want to say is that in the paper
that we wrote about this stuff we have
another protocol that handles general
deals in a synchronous model so we sort
of and that's a kind of that's a nice
protocol but I'm not going to talk about
that okay so the first thing happens is
somebody puts start deal starts the deal
up on the CBC so I there I'm showing you
that and an entry has showed up on the
CBC blockchain saying we're starting
deal D and D is a description of the
deal ok the parties are watching this
and then as soon as they see it and it
says the right thing they can all escrow
their assets ok so it's the same old
escrow there's the deal description a is
the asset there's some other stuff there
I'm not gonna come back to in a bit ok
after and and this is very different
from the previous protocol in the sense
that there's no order of things anymore
all parties can escrow their assets
immediately the reason for this is that
this protocol allows you to abort
whereas in the other protocol the order
of things in some sense when you put
your asset on the chain you were already
sort of committing yourself to the deal
and there wasn't much of a way to back
out but here you can put your stuff up
on the on the block chains with
confidence ok and then after stuff goes
up on the blockchain so you're watching
alright first you want to escrow your
assets then you want to do whatever
transfers are required so after the
escrow goes up the transfer goes up
actually I believe these probably could
happen in parallel but that's a
programming issue I mean in other words
you don't really have to work for the an
asset to be escrowed before you put the
transfer on the blockchain because they
could be executed in the reverse order I
mean we're used to doing that kind of
program anyway
what's showing up on each block on each
blockchain is in the simple cases first
an escrow get a transfer maybe another
transfer until each asset is
in a state where what the escrow says is
should this transaction commit this
particular asset will go to party
such-and-such so in our example the
ticket will be up there and the escrow
will say it's going to go to Carol and
the coins will be up there and it will
say a hundred are going to Bob and one
is going to Alice so you look at these
and and so you're watching your incoming
assets after you took care of your
outgoing assets and when you see that
one of your income your incoming asset
is exactly what you want then it goes
over on the CBC and actually if you
think about what I'm doing here it's
like two-faced can that turned upside
down because rather than having an
outside coordinator that's telling
everybody what to do we had this passive
blockchain that's being used as a
whiteboard where people are writing down
what they want to have happen to the
deal so if you're happy with what's
coming to you and you like the state of
the deal then you can say commit on the
CBC and each party does this
independently and if they all do it then
the transactions going to commit and if
somebody aborts before they all commit
then the thing will abort and if you say
commit and then things are taking too
long you can say abort later and what
matters is the order in which these
things show up on the blockchain that
determines the status of the deal yes
doesn't need to be there just omit that
first message well it has a lot of
information in it it says it has it
first of all it has a non-sentient so we
can be sure there's no replay attacks it
also has a list of participants it might
have other stuff I don't know I mean I
never thought about that question
whether you can get rid of the start
deal what's interesting is the start
deal comes from somewhere there might be
many of them because these are malicious
party so it's the first start deal that
matters and parties when they see that
start deal if they don't like it they
don't have to go ahead and and obey the
protocol one of the things that's nice
about this protocol is that everybody
acts for themselves everybody decides
what they like and what they don't like
and even if they are malicious they
can't hurt the others okay so I don't
know I'm a it's an interesting question
so in fact I mean I just wanted to say
it's the order of the votes that
determines the outcome it's flexible in
the sense that you could commit an abort
later if you don't like what's going on
parties better be careful because when
you say commit you better make sure that
what you're agreeing to is what you
really wanted by the way what you're
agreeing to isn't necessarily what you
signed up for so Alice might sign up for
different tickets than she thought she
was going to get but she decides do I
like it each person decides for
themselves but they better be careful
that they know what they're signing up
for and this increment means not just
their incoming assets but their outgoing
assets if you made a mistake in what you
put into escrow you know and you commit
tops of tough luck okay and as I said
parties can commit both to a commit and
later abort okay so really you yes
if let's say there are just two parties
one of them commits and the other one
takes a little longer so Bob and Carol
yep takes a little longer but finally
she sends her commits that coins Bob
decides to abort so now there is a race
between the awards and the committee
it's definitely a race but it's being
resolved at the CBC is a synchrony at
something who gets there first it's a me
the authority to also essentially
determine the outcome you know if
they're relays in the networks that are
getting both of these wrong way you're
absolutely right but what doesn't happen
what can't happen
let me just get to that for a minute and
just say
maybe I don't have it
I seem to have lost a slide okay so I'm
just gonna go backward and point out
okay what can't happen is this okay it's
true that the parties could get together
to block the deal you know so somebody
could decide I just want this deal to
abort no matter what this other guy
wants you're absolutely right about that
which can't do though is steal the
assets so basically this is a protocol
that comes down on the other side it
comes down on the side of safety as
opposed to like this I mean that's true
but that's not really what my point my
point is you can't cheat people like Bob
if the exchange rate
let's say of the two assets being
exchanged fluctuates there's the second
party to complete the trade as a free
option so they can choose to either like
abort or comet like effect change right
moved against the original price that
they have agreed
I think these protocols yes it does I
mean at the moment you decide to commit
at that point you're committed up to
that point you can change your mind but
you can't cheat somebody you know and
that's the point I mean other than that
yes you can always thinks fluctuate you
can change your name
I don't know maybe I more so I don't
know if I picked up on this question
properly but I think you means a
financial option like it's a derivative
so it's a cool yeah to buy at a certain
price to learn that's right but these
deals these deals are like that so they
don't they don't guarantee that the deal
will go through what they guarantee is
that either people get what they thought
they wanted or the assets are not lost
now you could imagine adding more to
this stuff like you know there's a
penalty for having been involved and so
forth and so on but I think this is in
the nature of the beast
yes if I sent comments and they they
want to abort abort is not guaranteed to
happen no it only will happen if it gets
on to the CBC before all the commits
show up and that's very important
because otherwise you would end up with
a state where some people would commit
and some would afford yeah
question okay okay let me just go
forward
okay so there's just a little problem I
haven't told you about yet okay so in a
way this is very nice it's like
two-phase commit and the truth is
sitting there on the whiteboard
but the problem is somehow you have to
get that information to the contracts
and blockchains aren't allowed to read
other blockchains which is actually a
good thing and so they can't go and look
at that blockchain and figure it out
instead the parties to the deal have to
tell them okay and the parties
themselves are malicious so if they
could figure out a way to mislead the
contract then they could do it so you
have to be careful and so the way you do
it is I seem to I keep getting ahead of
myself here is that the commit has to
contain a proof okay and this proof is a
clear description of the state of the
CBC just like we had a proof before but
there it was a sort of a simple idea of
releasing a secret here it's got to be
the state of the CBC and that's kind of
ugly
right I mean it could be that you have
to show the blockchain the entire CBC
from the start deal the first start deal
on the on the blockchain up to what I
call the definitive vote which is either
the last commit or the first abort and
that can be a lot of stuff okay and
that's not very desirable but if we're
using pbft and we can get by with the
certificate so if you think about the
CBC being executed by practical
Byzantine fault tolerance in some form
or other then what you have is you have
a bunch of replicas that you know
they're keys they can produce
certificates that can prove the case and
I want to just point out here that in
the entire CBC thing you can't omit
pieces you can't say here's just a
Merkel tree and I don't have to have
that block because there was nothing of
interest in there because that would
allow a dishonest party to skip over
pieces of the deal so it has to be a
very complete picture of the deal if I
go back to the way that pbft worked I
could just ask them a question I could
say what's the current status of the
deal and back would come a certificate
signed by F plus one which means that at
least one honest one said this is the
answer
telling me the status of the deal and of
course another thing is we get finality
which is kind of nice and you know
that's another issue that shows up in
the first one it's not just up to the
definitive vote there has to be many
more blocks before but we can be sure
that that definitive vote is really
there okay so yes it seems like this
you know the participants the validators
in the CBC each one of them with me to
understand or subscribe to every one of
the block chains that I don't know know
the CBC is totally separates just
another block chain and you can imagine
there are many CBC's so one of the
things that happens when you decide to
do a deal if you decide which CBC you're
going to use it's one of the parameters
you can choose and the CBC doesn't know
anything about what's going on in these
assets these these block chains it's
just itself whether they so they
understand they have a proof they
understand this is the state of the CBC
so they understand the stage in
practical Byzantine fault tolerance we
didn't store just modification commands
we also had queries and what queries did
is they didn't change the state but they
caused an answer to come back and the
answer would be signed you would accept
an answer as a client when you had
enough agreeing answer so you had a
certificate
yeah but I mean me may not be like that
maybe you don't want those queries there
but you have another way of asking
questions yeah CBC does not need to
understand than any other blockchain by
the court who you'll see bc need to
understand is a DC well if they were if
they were having to do it in the first
technique then yes they would have to
know the sort of the structure of that
CBC they'd have to understand even if
you imagine this is all the CBC does and
which might actually be a truth you know
you might imagine if the world has
organized this way that these CBC's are
very specialized to just managing this
kind of thing still that means every
blockchain would have to be reading the
blocks of the CBC so we'd have to
understand on the other hand if we go
for the practical business team
fault-tolerance all they have to know is
who the who the signers are and what
their what their public keys are and if
you imagine you have reconfiguration
going on with that CBC then they'd have
to know a little more they'd have to see
a chain maybe because they have to know
who were the signers for the start deal
so they can get started and then if
there were they have to find a chain if
things have changed since we started it
was placed there
one more question so this doesn't mean
that every chain involved in a deal with
in order to add a new CVC for example
every chain and it might want to use
that CBC would have to learn about the
new CBC and learn how to evaluate the
set of appropriate validator it doesn't
have to know the CBC it would have to
know the format of the CBC so we imagine
all the CBC's totally independent are
all running exactly the same set of
operations then you can imagine that
different CBC's
oh you're talking about this down here
ah yes well that actually is part of the
it's not part of the deal I really
didn't show it
but in those dot dot dots there on the
escrow what goes in there is the set of
public keys for the the replicas at that
moment in time so for the block that
contains the start deal we start off
with those public keys of the current
replicas that signed the block that
contains the start deal and from there
you can just march along
okay
and one thing I'd like to say about this
so let me just sort of finish this up
it's a shared resource unlike the
previous rep protocols which were don't
have any sharing but it works in the
synchronous network and it falls on the
side of safety rather than liveness if
there were an attack on the CBC that
caused it forever not to be able to do
something then you'd be stuck but of
course if there were such an attack
you're gonna be in pretty serious
trouble anyway you know the big
difference between synchronous and
asynchronous is that with synchronous
you have to say a time and guarantee
that stuff happens by then with
asynchronous what you say is it will
happen it's really eventually
synchronous but you don't have to
predict exactly if I win and in truth as
long as things are working there's not
that much difference but I like the fact
that things fail this way rather than
the other way I'd also think by the way
that this is a nice model for
distributed databases if you think about
transactions that spam database is
coming from different organizations
it seems nicer to have this passive
approach to managing things than the
active approach that people have looked
at in the past where there's this
external coordinator telling them all
what to do okay so I'm just gonna finish
up just a few questions about fault
tolerance yeah it's not like I mean you
know one everybody ports if everyone
just commits and communication is
reliable it's important please I'm just
talking about the problem that for some
reason there's been some sort of denial
of service on this attack on the CBC so
the CBC is not able to record these
things okay it's not lie its liveness
has nothing to do with the the members
of the deal because they can always time
out and decide to abort
okay so I just want to talk about
replication for a couple of minutes
practical Byzantine fault tolerance kept
a log like a block and a blockchain
but it's different from the way block
chains were described in the Bitcoin
paper because the idea there was that
the replication algorithm didn't know
anything about the content of the
message with a few exceptions like you
could ask it to give you some
non-deterministic value to use in your
computation so there were a few things
that knew but it didn't know much and in
particular didn't have to know they were
the application this meant those
requests could have been actually
encrypted so that there's no privacy
issues and there's another thing that's
even more important that I'll get to a
bit later so it's a different model of
computation it doesn't preclude having
things running yet at clients it was
really though a client-server model
where the idea was the work happened at
servers clients did queries and got the
answer signed by a sufficient number of
replicas so you could believe that it
was the truth okay my second question
not really you know I'm not working in
this area so and I've read some of the
papers about replication sort of based
on practical business for future fault
tolerance they're trying to go forward
what are the actual limits on how many
requests per second can be managed by
this replicated system and I think
that's an interesting question I think
it's interesting to ask the question
what applications do we know about and
what are their requirements I think it's
also an interesting question to ask how
fast can the system run and what I
really want to point out is that I don't
think that replication is the problem
here I mean remember we're working with
blocks we're advertising the cost of the
replication across a lot of requests
Bitcoin is very misleading because
that's an application that doesn't do
anything but in reality applications do
things and when they do things that's
work and you can't run this stuff faster
than the application it doesn't matter
because how fast the replication works
because the application has to do the
work so it is important to keep in mind
that there's a limit here on what's
going on you can't
exceed its exceeded and there is an also
an interesting question though if I
think about distributed I think about
databases running on a multi store which
is what I've been multi-core which I've
been working on recently the throughput
is incredible on those systems but they
get to find the order in which they do
transactions opportunistically here the
order is and sometimes predefined and
that means it's gonna slow you down so
an interesting question is how far can
you push this my second question our
next question is is sharding necessary
and I actually have to say that when I
think about sharding it sounds a lot
like working databases again where you
know if there's too many conflicts you
actually can't make progress if the
application really has a lot of work to
do and all this work is interconnected
so that you can't sort of separate
things out in a really natural way so
they don't interact very often you can't
make much progress so maybe what we're
talking about is just some sort of
partitioning which is the way you solve
stuff in database systems and then
finally I just want to say what is F
really ok this is not really a race to
the top it isn't interesting to ask the
question how big can f be and will the
system still work what is actually
interesting is the question how small
can f be and you know the fact that
we're spending so much money on the
power or wasting so much power to run
Bitcoin I mean we can't do things that
way we have to think in terms of what is
practically realistic so let me just
conclude with a few just to remind you
about some of the stuff that Miguel and
I talked about a long time ago
so amazed those days we were thinking
about a very small F okay and we were
worried about that small F and so we
pointed out a whole bunch of things you
wanted to think about about who those F
replicas were the first thing was they
better be distributed they had to be in
different data centers they had to be
geographically separated they maybe
belonged to different companies maybe
they were even in different countries so
you really wanted to separate them
secondly they better be dedicated
computers it's ridiculous to try and run
these algorithms on the computers your
employees are using on their desk
because the biggest threat to systems is
people falling for phishing attacks and
spam attacks and all that other software
they're running you know it has bugs in
it it just makes the whole thing
collapse so you really want them to be
dedicated computers and you want them to
be in a protected environment even if
they were dedicated computers if they
were just sitting out there in the
middle of the room that means you know
hundreds of people have access to them
if one of them has been corrupted okay
this is the insider attack you know then
you're toast you want a protected
environment where very few employees are
able to get in there to actually see the
hardware and furthermore you better keep
their secret keys hidden and you
probably got a shield that place you
know you don't want to have snooping
equipment that can find out the secret
keys because if the secret key is ever
exposed then there it is out in the
world and then I think you can go back
and start to rewrite history because you
can start to have a fork you know it's
really you don't have finality those
secret Keys really matter even if you're
doing reconfiguration you know if some
guy who was a replica last month knew at
secret key that can really cause damage
so we yell and I put that into a secure
coprocessor and of course there's been a
lot of work on how do you shield what
that computation in the secure POSCO
processor was doing but the idea was
that software didn't ever see the key
all I could do was ask for signing and
that's really
and then of course you know there's the
program correctness problem because no
matter how careful you are if there's a
bug in your code then there's a
possibility that all your replicas will
become bad simultaneously but honestly
program verification has come a long way
from where it was in 2000 and I think
that if you do some of the stuff we're
talking about and you think about pbft
by itself is not that complicated really
the operating system could be a
stripped-down operating system because
it's not a general-purpose computer it's
just for this function there's an
interesting question about the
application another point about this is
that if you separate the ordering of the
log from the application then you're
proving the correctness of something
much smaller of course that doesn't mean
the application doesn't have to work so
you have that problem too and then
finally I just want to remind you that
we talked about something called
proactive recovery and the idea there
was of course all you're requiring pbft
for safety is that no more than f
failures happen simultaneously and so we
were concerned about replicas are
getting compromised but if we constantly
reboot them from a secure coprocessor
that has the sort of the pure system
state then there won't we'll make a very
small window during which they could all
be compromised
so hardware's come quite a ways since
then this was paper was written almost
20 years ago but I just wanted to remind
you of all these questions because I
think they all are relevant to this
question of how can we keep the size of
F reasonable
[Applause]
okay this questions back there it's a
question that you heard about the
application latency what the operation
execution cost that's important one said
certainly if you look at the graphic
protocols that people dream up well
easily you spend a millisecond or two in
a signature verification and sometimes
people in Silla and thousands of
transactions per second throughput yeah
but they're partial answer and the
answer I wanted to give is that in out
logic fabric which was involved in the
design we have an answer to this
question where we separate the execution
of smart contracts from the critical
parts of the ordering because execution
execution takes place in a speculative
way like in a replicated database before
doubling is supported agreement on the
order is is reached so that's that - yes
I am aware of work like that you know
and I think Morris also did work like
that this sort of idea that you
speculate first and so and you can
retain information about the order and
use it later on and so forth I mean I
think this is all good stuff but I do
think there's a fundamental issue of how
much work you have to do to run the
application and that that's going to be
a deciding factor in how much throughput
you can get but of course you're gonna
try to make it run as fast as possible
and as I said in databases it's amazing
how about what the throughput is and
this is not really trivial stuff you
know these are actual transactions that
do work so it's not like all I did was
move a little money from here to there
so I think it's interesting area CBC's
often have to be a separate function or
it can also can it also be an asset it
could be one of the block chains they're
already using it just has to be a block
chain they agree on
but the real difference is they have to
all agree they're going to use that
block chain and that block chain has the
truth on it about the state of the deal
and databases there are a lot of
techniques for optimization that sort of
break down in an adversarial environment
where the participants and make sure
that there's always an opportune
ordering or set of transactions or set
of operations that will for example
speculative execution can be slower than
regular execution you end up having to
undo things a lot and so I'm wondering
if you thought about that about which
techniques work in an adversarial
environment and which ones don't
I hadn't thought about that at all I
think it's an interesting question
have a question soft do imagine Poland
so basically about that Bob know which
ticket is cheap this cheapest in which
it is extensive so Bob one to pilot
cheapest ticket and actually this really
relate to another province the produce
of the front Romney attack so I really
couldn't hear your question it was
something about Bob and tickets but I
did not pick up on anybody can somebody
caller and another guy that is most sale
ticket and one is tell point and another
cell is about 110 coin so they basically
involve water to five time you sort of
like an auction all right
by I rely on my friends here who are
more knowledgeable about because
blockchains than I am but my
understanding is that you have to put a
little bit of skin in the game in order
to make an auction work right so there
has to be some penalty for backing out
but otherwise this can handle auctions
he's not mentioning backing out but like
I'm about to propose a certain price and
somebody sees me broadcast and the
port's committed to the blockchain you
mention front running to get out well is
there anything different here than what
I just talked I mean what I'm saying is
there is there any difference between
this kind of protocol on the protocols
that use you know once the stuff is out
there people can see it it's an
advantage for
Yeah right I guess there's protocols
where you have to commit to everything
you're doing first to prevent run
running you add an extra stage basically
you use the hiding okay so as I say I
refer to my so this frost chain sports
in language of the nineties it's like
communicating replicated state machines
and the wonderful that this was a
question back then the width back then
it was just a giant who will talk to
replicate state machine or whether
there's the vault word on this issue
well so I was there then and my
recollection is nobody would have
dreamed of doing such a thing you know
we knew the world was a system can I run
transactions in a synchronous model and
you know talk it was interesting was
going from from two-phase commit to this
was took quite a bit of time because it
sort of turns upside down and the fact
that everybody can lie as a little sort
of demotion dr. gilda same CBC could to
services communicate to play as if there
are one CBC you know we just came up
with this recently and
I mean clearly there's issues here like
who do you trust and it's not even clear
I mean you need to add something to it
in some way I have I suspect not worse
I'm looking at you I wouldn't do it that
way divorces I suspect not I think you
have to have we have each group that
wanted to do the deal would have to
agree on a particular sensation somewhat
in the respect to make a bit there were
less would be of the same citizen it's
kind of a fair exchange right you need
to trust that party to solve it Michael
chips in your joint if isn't immediately
which is the same thing as you're not
forced to even after the the everything
in the accessory you can say now I'm not
going
so there's no this requirement oh yeah
but in the ferret sense you have to
parties and want to extend assets right
and either both get what they want or
not which is not happening here because
if one aborts then of course whatever
and that's the whole requirement because
I believe you need a single CPC we sort
of prove that you need some sort of
single shared resource in order to have
a protocol like this work and it has to
do with the old Fisher Lynch paper and
how you know in a distributed system you
can't control without time you can't
order things in the same way at multiple
sites it's a challenge I'll take it
offline so earlier you mentioned how
like there can be like observability
basically between two letters how if I
have a ledger and I want to inspect the
state of the other ledger it's
impossible in this situation and you do
from my view list you do the lack of
some objective metric to verify that the
ledger is at a specific state and hence
why you do why you have to do this
two-phase commit if you're trying to my
question is like if you're trying to
observe the state of a proof-of-work
exchange so know that they give the
change then you use the work itself to
verify that the transaction so that the
first like transaction of your swap has
happened so I would send them the money
like for some address and then at the
other party like has not proved that the
moment I have sent the money to the
address they have enough proof to just
get the assets that I had Logan
this allows it to do it like in one less
like transaction while also removing the
need for them
well the tricky part here is that when
you remove the money how do you make
sure that the other guy gets what you're
giving in exchange using years like the
work itself like so that's why I'm
saying that they like in a pbft order
like something like non like some
mechanism where it's not expensive like
to create this attack this wouldn't work
but like improve avoid change perhaps
this would be like Emily what he's
saying so how do you communicate that to
the other player that doesn't know that
much right so you have to be you have to
be remaining the kind difficulty and you
can always calculate the time if I'm
feeding your fork all the time Colette
differently and cutting your network of
the mains and your loves it's Paul from
work you signal to age we might wanna
add two bullet points one is secure hard
work for forcing guaranteeing
phenomenal rationality guarantees that
you're incentivized to behave thank you
I think that something like the CBC
implemented in reality you would want I
mean I was talking about some of the
stuff so secure hard work yes and yes I
mean when you start to think about who
would be providing the replicas that
make up this you know I wouldn't want
them all at one company if I was doing
something that even I might be happy to
have them all in the United States if I
was doing something that was with the
United States it's much harder to know
what to do when it's China in the United
States and I agree there's a lot of lack
of trust there yes I agree and I think
coming up with a set of requirements
would be a good thing
so
any more questions
I have one more going back to the where
you started before of your teeth used
after application and taxes you know a
success earning story of similar ideas
similar techniques different formalisms
I guess there were a lot of papers
reason but the nuance differences second
or third order right the community was
working towards the same solutions so I
wonder if you could finish with some
some comments about this this process of
collaborative scientific innovation that
advances the state of art well yes I was
just gonna I'm gonna in the in the
spirit of let's just finish with
something what I'll tell you about is
that when I invented data abstraction
way back in 1973 that idea was floating
in the air and other people were
thinking of similar things you look at a
paper written by Jim Morris at about
that time you can kind of see data
abstraction working in there even though
we didn't pick it out so it's absolutely
true that in a community a research
community people who are thinking about
similar issues are sort of coming up
with similar ideas and it's just the way
it is I just happened to be lucky that I
came up with that idea and wrote a paper
and got that paper out you know with
that idea in it before anybody else
managed to pin it down but it was not
true that I mean if I hadn't done it
somebody else would have done it and so
this is not exactly an answer to your
question but it's sort of the way you
know things work what was a little odd
about the story with yeah I mean what
would really happen with you stamp
replication and paxos is kind of a it's
a it's a commentary on both me and
Leslie I mean what Leslie says now is I
came up with the name she actually
implements you know but but you know
it's it's actually he kept expressing it
in terms of proofs and that made it
difficult for people to follow it
I did it in terms of here's a protocol
you can follow but what I didn't do was
I didn't pull that out and separate the
protocol from the application that was
sitting behind it and if I had done that
then I think people would have
understood a lot better and actually
when I look back on my career I see
other things like didn't you do and you
know you're always making decisions when
you're doing research about do I do this
or do I that do that and I had a
tendency to say I did that I'm going to
go on to something else
and that's you that is what you want to
do because you don't want to sit there
spending three years just kind of
cleaning up little details but on the
other stand you know I invented my group
invented parametric polymorphism for
clue and it's there in the reference
manual and it's there in the paper that
describes clue but we should have
written a paper about parametric
polymorphism and how you implement it
and so forth and that might have been a
real help to the programming language
committee where it didn't well it took
until Haskell you know Haskell came out
with its I forget what they're called
but anyway the things that they used to
describe what we called where clauses
that's 30 years I mean that's ridiculous
so it's there's a fine line here between
moving forward and spending a little
more time and I think I are sometimes
move forward a little too fast
anyway thank you very much
[Applause]